Hi everyone.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm Jamie,
Jamie Jones and I'm a professor in earth system science at Stanford.
Uh,
I'm actually trained as an anthropologist,
but I sit in the school of Earth,
energy and the environment at Stanford in the department of Earth System
Science.
So today I'm going to talk to you about some recent interests I've had in uh,
in applying evolutionary and ecological ideas to economics and decision theory.
Um,
this interest was peaked by my attempt to understand the peculiarities of the
human life cycle and our life cycles are really peculiar.
I can assure you in a broad comparative context,
they're really kind of weird.
Um,
and to understand the reason people in subsistence economies pursue particular
types of,
of resources,
pray and a forge food and that sort of thing.
And so I'm going to guide you through a big picture view of some fairly
technical fields today that include population biology,
uh,
decision theory,
a bit of economics,
both classical and,
and,
uh,
behavioral.
But I think the ultimate message is pretty straight forward.
And the thing that sort of broad picture that motivates me is understanding how
something like this,
which was,
uh,
an artist's reconstruction of,
of Australopithecus Afarensis,
which is essentially a one meter tall chimpanzee like thing that walked up,
right?
Right.
It's got a 300 cubic centimeter brain,
so about a quarter of the size of maybe a little less than a contemporary human,
a very sexually dimorphic.
The males are much bigger than females.
Uh,
they had enormous,
a cheek teeth,
uh,
for meeting and very tough diet.
Um,
and as I said,
they're,
they're really tiny.
These guys,
uh,
lived about three and a half million years ago in east Africa and
transitioned in,
this probably doesn't look that different,
I guess.
Um,
but it is,
it's fundamentally different in about one and a half,
1.8 million years ago,
and this critter called Homo ergaster.
Uh,
for my purposes is,
is effectively modern.
You've got a large body size,
so within the normal range of contemporary human variation,
you've got body proportions that looked very much like people living in the
tropics.
Today,
you've got a great reduction in sexual size.
Dimorphism so that males and females are,
are similarly proportion to how they are today relative to each other.
And you've got big brains.
They're not,
they're smaller than modern,
but they're actually within the range of variation on the low end of variation
of contemporary humans.
Uh,
Homo ergaster sometimes called a African homo erectus is the first of our to to
leave Africa and to colonize the rest of the world.
Um,
and it did so around,
you know,
1.8 million years ago,
give or take a little bit.
And so my question is,
how is it that a population of bipedal apes,
you know,
they're not very impressive looking,
right?
Kind,
Kinda like we aren't,
right?
We don't have big weapons,
we don't have antlers or horns,
we don't have big teeth.
We don't have,
uh,
the sort of ferocity built into us.
We have some cleverness maybe,
uh,
but how is it that in less than 2 million years,
which is a very rapid period of time in the broader span of evolution,
how is it that we went from this small population of African apes,
bipedal apes,
and I've grown to a size of 7 billion souls in,
as I say,
less than 1.8 million years.
Okay.
And we've colonized and come to dominate nearly every terrestrial biome,
right?
It's just a picture of making the desert green and the Arabian peninsula as a,
as a sort of indicator of the extent to which we really dominate,
uh,
the world,
30 to 40% of net primary productivity is captured by human actions,
right?
So the phenomenal growth of our species in this very short period of time
suggest that our ancestors on average,
must've made pretty good decisions,
right?
Because the decisions they made led them to increase,
uh,
in,
in pretty great numbers.
But there's a torrent of work in psychology and economics represented by just a
few sample publications here of,
of semi popular trade books.
So just a decision made,
the decision making software that our brains run,
which is presumably essential to our,
our ecological domination,
uh,
is profoundly flawed.
That in a,
in a word we're irrational.
How's it possible that a species apparently so defective and its ability to
generate sound decisions can be so incredibly evolutionary,
evolutionary,
least successful?
Uh,
I'll just say as a relative outsider,
um,
I'll make this observation about this particular body of work that I'm
discussing here.
Uh,
in the slide.
There are lots of anomalies.
Like we see these things that don't make sense from the way we sort of think
about the way people should make decisions.
Um,
and,
and you can write whole books on this,
like lots of books on this,
but they're generally unconnected and the whole area,
it seems to lack of sort of unifying theory.
I'm going to humbly submit that.
I think that evolution can help us provide some of the theory that brings
together some of these anomalies.
There's a tendency in particular in like in,
in the Ted talks where there's real selection for being provocative,
right?
To suggest that that people are irrational because they don't follow the rules
of formal.
We're actually Madec rationality theory.
However,
every economic decision entails and optimization problem.
And,
and I feel like I'm,
I'm on safe ground when I'm at Google talking about optimization problems,
right?
That,
and if you want to solve an optimization problem,
what do you need?
Well,
you need to know who's doing the optimizing.
You need to know the actor,
but you need to know the objective function,
right?
And if you get the objective function wrong,
you're going to get the solution wrong,
okay?
And it doesn't matter what your optimization problem is,
right?
It could be an engineering problem,
it could be a portfolio design and investment portfolio design.
It could be about insurance and getting the best mixture of wild foods to ensure
growth and survival,
right?
But you need to get the objective function right.
And I'm going to suggest that in general,
we don't have a very solid understanding of what the objective function is that
people are using when they're making economic decisions broadly.
Okay?
And the results appear anomalous.
When you get,
when you use the wrong objective function,
you get the wrong answer.
And I think that evolution helps weave together theoretically what are otherwise
a series of unconnected anomalies.
Um,
so we,
we liked this coherence.
Uh,
and I think these may be brought together if we understand what sort of problems
the human brain is actually designed to solve.
Okay.
Um,
get the right objective function and you have a chance,
a chance,
I'm not 100% convinced to this.
This is fairly new for me,
but I feel like there's a real chance that we can begin to understand,
uh,
the,
this sort of broader theory of,
of choice.
Um,
so the two things that we really need,
I think our evolutionary theory,
which guides our choice of what's being optimized,
it gives us a clue as to what the likely objective function that our brains are
designed to solve or to optimize.
And secondly,
it's really important that we get broad comparative data to help us understand
the conditions that favor good decision making.
It turns out that different groups of people make more or less good decisions,
right?
It's not everybody who's a complete idiot and behaves irrationally.
Okay.
And,
and we,
we sort of limit ourselves a lot in,
in the sort of people that we inquire about,
about,
um,
decision making.
I'm going to focus primarily on the evolutionary theory and give you just some
hints of some work that we've done.
A without getting bogged down in the technique,
technical details.
But I think that the comparative data is really important as well.
Uh,
and then use this word fitness and he used it a lot and a evolutionary success
is determined by fitness.
And the problem with fitness is it's one of these super fraught terms,
right?
That that has lots of colloquial meanings that can kind of interfere with our
rigorous understanding and analysis of it.
So when I talk about fitness,
uh,
I'm talking about the relative contribution that an individual makes to future
populations.
So if you have some heritable trait,
whether its anatomical or physiological or behavioral,
marginally increasing the representation of its bearers and future generations,
the population is going to evolve towards that trait.
This is the fundamental logic of selection,
right?
And,
uh,
and,
and fitness is the evolutionary objective function.
It is the subject of evolutionary optimization.
Okay.
So just wanting to get that out of the way.
I'm going to give you
a quick preview of the approach that we use and thinking about this.
Um,
uh,
sort of more formally the organs that make our economic decisions right there.
Oregon's just like our liver is just like our heart is presumably these have
been under intense selection.
And part of the reason,
just as an aside,
part of the reason we think that brains should be under intense selection is not
just because they're useful,
but because they're super costly,
right?
The brain is an incredibly costly thing to carry around.
It entails mortality costs for,
for mothers,
right?
Because if we get this cephalopelvic disproportion,
big brains have to come through a limited pelvic cavity when,
when they're born brains use 20% of of oxygen at rest right there.
Super costly.
The fact that they exist and that they've gotten bigger over time suggest that
there's a reason they're there.
Right?
Um,
so,
uh,
people with good decision making capabilities presumably in the past,
resulted in leaving more descendants and became disproportionately represented
in the,
in the population to the extent that economic decisions affect fitness,
we should expect outcomes to track fitness interests more than some arbitrarily
defined standard form.
A standard of formal rationality.
Okay.
So let me just walk you through a little bit of the logic here of the model and
then I'm going to move away from it and go and,
and go on to talking about some,
uh,
some features of the human evolutionary environment.
So it's a hierarchical model.
At the bottom we have economic decisions,
right?
These are about the sorts of things you hunt for,
the sort of things you put in your market basket,
the decisions you're making on a day to day basis.
About your,
your livelihood,
right?
And these feed into what we think of as like proximate motivators.
These are the things that you're,
you're sort of striving for,
uh,
in approximate way happiness or,
or sexual gratification or satiety,
right?
The things that motivate you to eat or to have sex or to do things that are
meaningful in your life.
But these then presumably have an impact on,
on fitness.
And we can think of as a fitness here as an aggregator,
something that aggregates and averages over these different,
uh,
than my pointer doesn't work these different,
um,
uh,
goals which are fed into by,
these economic decisions.
Okay.
So that's a,
a preview of the type of reasoning that we're using.
I'll come back to this and a little bit,
but I do want to mention,
you know,
I said that the,
the two things that we need,
I think we need to evolutionary theory.
I think we also need broad comparative data on the decision making of actual
people in particularly people who are good at making decisions under tremendous
constraints.
And this is just a selection of a bunch of people.
They've written some books,
right?
And it turns out that somewhat to the surprise of,
of much of the,
the institution of,
uh,
studying,
economic decision making,
that poor people often make incredibly savvy decisions,
right?
They face enormous constraints.
But when you adjust for that,
when you control for the fact that there are constraints set is very limited,
right?
That their strategy said is very limited and they're under a tremendous
constraint.
Poor people tend to make very good decisions in part because it really matters
to them.
Okay.
And so I'm going to leave that,
this is another big part of,
uh,
the broader work that I'm doing,
but I want to focus on,
on more the,
the,
um,
the sort of evolution part,
the economic decisions I'm going to talk about and show you some pictures of,
uh,
typically send her on on subsistence populations and the,
you know,
the things look a little exotic,
but the sorts of decisions that people make and subsistence economies are
fundamentally no different than the types of decisions that we make on a regular
basis.
Right?
What,
how do you fill your market basket?
Given a fixed a budget,
right?
It may not be money,
it may be time,
it may be political capital,
but,
uh,
you're,
you're doing very much the same sort of thing.
And one of the,
and basically my argument is that we have to think about humans as biological
entities.
We've been shaped by selection,
um,
and that our decision making capabilities have fundamentally been shaped by,
by,
uh,
by this,
this evolutionary heritage as a to a biological entity.
Economic decisions are not arbitrary preference orderings right there,
which is sort of the way you typically will learn about them in a micro
economics class,
for example,
it turns out that the rules for living organism anchored in the present and
subject to a force of selection that really doesn't like extinction,
right?
Fitness is a multiplicative process,
In order for your lineage to persist,
it has to persist every generation.
You can't get a zero in there or it's an absorbing boundary,
right?
So you really want to avoid those zeros.
Um,
I'll show that the all important need to avoid extinction in a world that's an
incompletely known at best has profound implications for preferences,
utility and nationality.
And uh,
one of the key things I think that comes out of this,
um,
is it ignoring the condition of existential uncertainty by doing that,
the,
the theory of,
of rational decision making is developed a distorted expectation of how
organisms working in their own interest,
uh,
should behave.
Okay.
So,
uh,
a bunch of the work I've done on this is in collaboration with my colleagues,
Rebecca and Doug Bird.
Uh,
and just to give you a sampling of the types of economic decisions we tend to
think about,
do you hunt for Atlanta,
which are these,
these monitor lizards that live in the desert of Western Australia or do you
hunt for hill kangaroo,
right.
There are different payoffs are different risks associated with this.
If you're a subsistence farmer in this is in Uganda,
another place where I work,
do you plant maize dude plant yams or do you forego subsistence crops altogether
and take your,
take a stab at the,
at the cash economy.
This is coffee,
uh,
working with,
a postdoc,
Ashley Hazel in Southern Africa in Namibia.
You know,
we're,
we're asking the sort of questions,
how do people,
particularly women manage social relationships to manage,
to manage the extreme uncertainty of living in essentially a desert and trying
to raise cattle,
trying to raise crops,
trying to raise children,
right?
Trying to keep your yourself going in a very difficult environment.
So these are the types of economic decisions that I tend to think about.
But as I say,
there,
no,
they're fundamentally no different than going shopping,
buying a house,
doing the sorts of things that economists tend to look at.
The history of this for me,
uh,
goes back to my former phd student like price,
who's now a post doc at the Santa Fe Institute.
And Mike was interested in understanding the origins of Sago,
palm farming in,
uh,
in Southeast Asia.
Um,
Sago Palm.
It's an amazing crop.
It's one of the,
it's one of the senators of,
of agricultural innovation in and around New Guinea and the South Pacific,
uh,
Southeast Asia.
Um,
a single Sago palm tree.
We'll,
we'll met literally millions of calories in starchy flower,
right?
That you,
that you can make into a grill.
Um,
that's,
that's very calorically dense that catches it takes 25 years for a Sago palm to
develop to maturity and to the point where it can be harvested.
And trying to understand the evolution of this remarkable horticultural system.
Let us to think hard about,
uh,
economic topics such as time and risk preferences,
preferences,
and economic decisions.
Generally,
it's hard to make a sort of standard economic model that says,
okay,
for go the immediate reward activities you're pursuing right now and go plant
some Sago Palm and wait 25 years.
Right?
That's a,
that's a hard problem to solve.
But clearly it happened at some point.
So that's where all this really started thinking.
And Mike and I have been working together for a few years on this stuff.
So a theme that emerged in our work is that,
is it a biological entity?
Trying to maximize fitness will behave in ways that often really mimic the
anomalies that you see in this behavioral economics and psychology literature.
We weren't looking to show that,
but we found how,
you know,
people said,
hey,
you know,
that kind of looks like prospect area.
Is that really I that surprises me.
So they'll do things like use non unexpected utility,
right?
Uh,
I don't get into what that,
what that necessarily means.
Happy to talk about it later.
They'll frequently violate the axioms of rational choice.
Uh,
they'll seemingly have inconsistent time preferences,
right?
They'll,
um,
I mean from the perspective of an economic decision,
these may appear irrational,
but these behaviors are the sort of things that keep you alive in,
in a variable and uncertain environment.
Okay.
Um,
so rather than the mathematicians,
a formal axiomatic rationality,
people seem to use a procedural rationality.
And this is a point that the,
the great in a polymath economist Herbert Simon suggested in his scissors
metaphor,
right?
The,
that trying to understand decision making is like trying to understand the way a
pair of scissors work.
You've got on the one hand the computational capacities,
but on the other hand you've got the task environment trying to understand the
computational capacities,
like the logical rules of cognition without understanding the environment is
like trying to understand half a pair of scissors doesn't work very well.
Okay.
I said that their selection and Ted talk like environments for saying
provocative things.
This is a slightly provocative thing,
Darwin saying it.
Um,
economics is an actually a science,
right?
And I,
this isn't meant as a put down,
it's,
it's a statement of fact and it's because the,
the preferred and overwhelmingly the dominant mode of economic theory
generation,
it's axiomatic,
right?
And that's not the way the natural sciences proceed.
Behavioral Economics and,
and this great field of experimental developmental economics has changed this by
actually measuring the way people behave rather than sort of specifying the way
that they're expected to behave.
But I think there's still a decent amount of,
of baggage.
What do I mean when I say axiomatic?
Standard economic theory generation starts from a series of axioms,
right?
Primitive assumptions that are taken to be self evident.
Things like you shouldn't reverse your preferences if you prefer a to B and B to
c,
you should prefer a to see that's a,
that's an axiom of transitivity.
Right?
And that makes total sense.
But there's nothing that guarantees that that's right.
There's nothing that guarantees it.
That's the way the universe works.
It's just a logical rule that we said I can live with that.
Right?
And so,
um,
you take these axioms,
you derive out the way you expect a rational agent to behave.
And this is what economic theory really is all about.
It,
it's normative.
It describes how actors should behave.
Science on the other hand is positive,
right?
It starts from observations about the world and attempts to explain them as
inferred through observed data.
It's inductive,
right?
The theory plays the role of generating hypotheses,
which can then be confronted with additional data,
right?
And so,
um,
it's a common and it's a well state and critique of that neoclassical economic
theory describes the behavior of a species other than humans.
And it's referred to tongue in cheek,
uh,
by the fake Latin binomial,
binomial,
homo economic us.
Right?
Uh,
and while it's true that humans do not behave according to the classical
expectations,
are these neoclassical expectations,
you know,
the,
the expectations weren't designed to actually explain,
observe behavior,
right?
So we shouldn't be that surprised by it,
I think.
So I'm going to talk to you about what,
right now for a little bit about,
uh,
what I think the really important bits of,
of,
of our human evolutionary legacy are for understanding the way we make decisions
about things.
And I'm going to dive down fairly deep into,
into my specialty area,
which is called life history theory.
So I'm going to suggest that humans are adapted to environmental uncertainty.
And
this is a,
I think,
a pretty telling graphics.
So what I've got here is its temperature proxy data.
So this is inferred temperature,
uh,
by million years before presence.
So we're going from more ancient to more recent humans are a product of what's
called the pleistocene,
which is a,
a geological epoch that spans from about 1.8 million years ago to about 10,000
years ago.
And the two things that should be really obvious from this plot are that one,
the earth is cooled in the last 5 million years.
It's actually cooled considerably more in the last 25 million years.
It's cooled and it's gotten more variable.
Okay?
And you can't actually see it on here.
We know that in places,
particularly in Africa,
um,
where,
uh,
there's been a lot of interest in this.
There's actually a decadal scale variation here,
like enormous environmental variation going on that really gets amplified in
this period,
uh,
where our genus emerged,
which is this,
this pink line here.
Okay?
And just while I'm on the subject of temperature,
global temperature,
right?
You'll sometimes see people say,
well,
you know,
the earth used to be much warmer.
We can let it get warm it,
it'll be fine,
maybe.
Sure.
But we're a cold planet species,
right?
We are adapted to a cooler planet.
Just,
you know,
something to bear in mind.
The origin story of the human lineage and the,
and the genus.
Homo in particular is a story of moving from a primarily Arboreal,
uh,
lifestyle in tropical ever moist forest.
This is a chimpanzee,
uh,
foraging for,
you can see the fruits up in the top of the picture there and the New England
forest.
And in,
in Rwanda,
we moved from these forests onto this sort of mixed scrubbed Savannah.
This is a picture from Serengeti National Park in Tanzania.
And moving onto the Savannah entailed a bunch of new challenges right there,
big predators there.
There are a lot of them.
They're big and they're scary.
Uh,
but it also changes the way food is distributed,
right?
And then here's a picture of a chimpanzee present,
uh,
the Kamali National Park and,
and he's looking down at me and,
and he's got an enormous pile of figs here.
And this tree,
I don't want to exaggerate,
but it certainly had tens of thousands of figs,
possibly hundreds of thousands,
possibly well into the hundreds of thousands of things.
These tropical things are incredibly productive.
They're asynchronous breeders,
so they breed sort of throughout,
throughout the year.
They fruit throughout the year.
They're not really high quality.
Like you wouldn't want to make a Newton out of them,
right?
You're not going to make figgy pudding with these cause they taste like crap,
I assure you.
But when there's no good fruit in the forest,
chimps,
we'll happily eat this and this is in general what the great apes do.
They fall back when their preferred foods aren't there onto this lower quality
stuff and figs are a great thing.
And any tropical forest,
we go out into the Savannah,
there no there,
there isn't much fruit.
What?
There are our underground storage organs,
so these are a bunch of Hadza tubers that my former postdoc Brian would took a
picture of and they look like sticks,
don't they?
It doesn't that look delicious,
right?
Try to eat that and you're going to spend like 12 hours just chewing on it.
Your,
your,
your jaws are going to be so tired.
You have to have fire basically in order to,
you scorch them,
he burned them and you make them chewable.
There's a lot of stored starch in there and it makes for a great fallback food,
but they're very different than figs.
They're widely distributed.
They're not at all clumped.
Right.
You're never going to find a patch,
you know,
just start digging.
Oh yeah.
And you've got to dig for them cause they're underground.
But you got to start digging.
You're not going to find 100,000 tubers there,
right?
Like you're going to find 100,000 figs in a tree,
so you have to spread out your effort.
Right?
It changes the economics of,
of,
uh,
foraging tremendously.
Uh,
and here's Brian,
uh,
who's,
you know,
one of the world authorities on the Hud's a hunter gatherers and Tanzania and
his hair really is fascinating.
So,
uh,
he gets that a lot.
He's now a professor down at Ucla.
Um,
so moving from the force of the sedan and beyond increases as the variability in
food intake,
right?
Because it's a drier environment,
it's a less productive environment.
There are lots of opportunities,
but there are also lots of challenges.
And while there's certainly more sort of meat on the huff,
your,
your ability to sort of manage your downside,
I think is a,
is,
is much harder on the Savannah.
And so this is why adaptation does uncertainty as a central part of being human,
right?
Humans move out of the forest onto the Savannah and it's a much more variable
place.
And this,
this variability is not just,
you know,
you don't just like set up an experiment and measure the variability and get
your nice distribution that you fit to it and say,
okay,
14% of the time I'm going to have to do this and the 27% of the time I'm going
to have to do this the way a risk manager would do it.
There's real uncertainty here.
You really don't know what the probabilities are in part because the environment
is,
is very rapidly changing.
So when I say uncertainty,
I mean uncertainty and not risk.
Um,
adaptation,
doubt,
uncertainty is central to being human.
There are all these things that we do that are very unusual.
We haven't expanded diet as I've mentioned,
you know,
that typically requires technology to extract like,
like,
uh,
these underground storage.
Oregon's,
we are the mobile primate,
right?
Our home ranges for like a hunter gather,
uh,
is on the order of 10 to a hundred times bigger than a,
than a comparable size chimpanzee group.
Okay.
So like the Hadza range over about 2,500 square kilometers,
whereas a chimpanzee group will range over about 20.
Now the chimps live in a forest,
so you know,
there is that difference,
but that's part of moving out onto the Savannah and where the,
where the huddle live.
Humans are so mobile,
right?
When things get really bad,
we get up and we moved continents,
right?
This is very much a timely issue,
The 21st century in the latter part of the 20th,
first century is going to be dominated by human mobility,
right?
We,
we,
we see that it's breaking lots of international systems right now and possibly
leading to the rise of right wing or right wing extremism,
right?
Migration is part of our story from the outset.
Um,
the other really big thing that we do that we're really known for,
and that's very unusual,
right,
is we share food.
And it's so unusual,
we don't even think about how weird it is that a bunch of unrelated males
doesn't matter.
It males,
females can sit in a room and share food together and like not want to kill each
other.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't wanna speak for you,
but I can sit in a room with people.
People are eating.
I don't feel like I need to go,
you know,
get all dominant or something.
Right?
This is weird,
right?
You talk about your dog and all the unconditional love of a dog.
I've got an idea.
Why don't you try pulling your dog's food bowl and eating from it?
See if that love is so unconditional,
right?
It's a weird thing that people do.
We share food all the time and hunter gathers,
it's,
it turns out to be a super risky and uncertain endeavor to go hunting those hill
kangaroos.
85% of all hunting bouts end with zero calories.
Netted.
Okay.
85%.
So these are,
uh,
mixed,
hunter gatherers in,
in the Canadian Arctic,
my student Elspeth ready gather these data heroically over two years.
It's an incredible,
incredible story.
Um,
and it's just the show.
I mean she,
she also makes it really pretty graphics,
but it's just to show you that,
that by having these networks of food sharing,
right,
you insure against you failing on any given day,
you can count on getting food from someone else.
So this is also a very unusual thing that people do.
Right.
And,
and this is part of the argument for this embodiment of yeah.
Uh,
so the,
the red houses or are food insecure,
right?
And the,
and the blue ones are food secure.
It's actually,
yeah,
it's actually a very complicated graphic.
I just show it cause it's nice.
Uh,
so those are a few,
few ways we manage uncertainty.
But my main focus is on the evolution of our life cycles,
right?
How long we live,
why we reproduce,
when we do the patterns of,
of reproduction,
that sort of thing.
And I would suggest uncertainties embodied fundamentally in our reproductive
biology.
Humans are really unusual.
I mentioned that we are peculiar in our life cycles.
We have probably the latest age at first reproduction of any mammal.
Um,
it's very late.
Uh,
we've got high fertility given how,
you know,
we've got low fertility when you compare us to like a pig,
right?
We have singletons and we spread them out pretty well.
And just pigs,
we'll have a litter of 13 or piglets or whatever.
Right?
But for our body size and for how late we begin reproducing,
we are,
we are very fecund.
We,
uh,
have a fertility rate that's about 50% higher than chimpanzees for instance.
And natural fertility populations.
We have a super long reproductive span.
You start reproducing at around age 20 or so and 45 50.
That's a long time to be reproducing for any mammal.
Um,
and we've got extensive periods of overlap of dependence.
And,
and I,
this is another picture from Brian would among the Hadza,
this beautiful Hadza a family with a mother with her for dependent children and
her mother who allows her to keep these four beautiful children alive by
subsidizing her foraging effort and her time and providing this,
this babysitting.
I think this picture embodies a lot of the peculiarities of the human life
cycle,
uh,
among them include substantial post reproduction,
post reproductive lifespan,
right?
Which is something that most animals don't have.
So let's look a little,
little data.
Uh,
I've got a database of about 1400 mammal species here.
and I've just plotted things out as a function of body size.
Biological things tend to scale with body size and,
and um,
uh,
the,
the modal Mammo weighs about 50 grams,
right?
So there are lots of little things,
there are fewer big things.
That's one of those things that scales with body size.
So you put these on double logarithmic axes and the red,
uh,
points are primates.
The black points are all other mammals and the green are humans.
And so we can see that for,
uh,
our body mass.
We have a very late age at first reproduction.
We have a very long lifespan and we have low fertility,
but we're not quite the same outlier that we are in age of first reproduction in
lifespan.
We're kind of in with all the other great apes in terms of our fertility.
You don't really see how freakishly different we are,
how weird we are until you start to combine the parameters.
And this is also a sort of engineering kind of idea.
You have these different parameters,
they have different,
different units on them.
Let's combine them and make some dimensionless numbers and try to get out of the
design features of the organism.
Okay.
And this a life history theorist return off showed that,
uh,
what I'm calling it's,
it's the,
um,
it's the ratio of agent first reproduction to total reproductive lifespan.
And I'm calling that relative lifespan is co is constant across mammals.
Okay.
And we can see for,
I've got the four great apes here for the,
the,
the three nonhuman grade eight eights.
You can see it's,
it's remarkably constant.
Uh,
the same thing is true for the,
it's the product of age.
At first we production in annual fertility,
I've called it reproductive power here and it's a little more variable,
but it's,
you know,
constant enough for comparative biology considering these things are measured
with a lot of slop.
How do humans fit in?
So our,
our relative lifespan is really right in the ballpark of the great of the other
great apes.
What about our reproductive power
too?
Right?
So way more than double what pretty much all the other mammals are.
This is the thing that's really peculiar about humans.
So we live a long time,
but we actually also make a lot of babies,
right?
And those things typically don't go together.
Uh,
I suggested that a few years back that this pattern,
a very long life and very high reproductive powers consistent with a strategy
known as bad hedging humans are bet hedgers the long generation length that
comes from a late age of first reproduction and along reproductive span coupled
with relatively high fertility means that you get the sample multiple
environments.
Think back to the,
that plot of,
of,
of temperature over time and you know,
zoom into a,
a more local timescale.
It's varying quite a bit,
right?
There's decadal scale variation that we know is going on in the place to seen in
Africa.
And you,
if you could,
if you had great information,
right?
You can say,
ah,
I know that this is going to be a great year to reproduce and you could pile all
your reproduction into it,
right?
But if you're wrong,
you're completely hosed,
right?
Because you've put all your eggs in one basket,
Bed hedging is all about spreading out your risk,
doing it a lot and trying to sample abroad temporal,
um,
a series of environments.
The essence of bed hedging is trading off the mean for reduction in fee and
variants.
And I should mention,
you know,
the term comes from the racetrack betting strategy where you bet at least a
little money on every single horse in a race,
right?
And what that means is that you're guaranteed to lose money every race,
but you're also guaranteed not to lose it,
all right?
Because some horse has to win and you know,
you don't just like lay it out at random.
Presumably you have an idea about which horse is going to win,
but you had yourself.
Right?
And so hedging of course is,
is,
uh,
you know,
diversification in general.
It's right.
It's the fundamental strategy for risk management.
Okay.
But why hedge bets and why should humans in particular need to hedge
my hedge humans inherited a legacy of slow reproduction from the Great Apes,
right?
We,
we come from this great apes stock and we have very low in the broader scheme of
things,
reproductive capacity.
So under the best of circumstances,
a chimpanzee population is going to grow at about 1% annually.
If everything comes together just perfectly.
And the higher the growth rate,
the less likely a population will go extinct.
As humans moved into more variable Savannah woodland environments,
they experience greater variance.
And you can show right the,
that your long run expectation is essentially,
it's a function of your mean.
That's also a function of your variance.
Variance pushes you symmetrically around a mean.
And when you have an absorbing boundary,
right?
That that's a bad thing.
You want to avoid getting pushed around that mean,
right?
So prolific reproduction is sort of the other way you do this.
Like if you're a muscle or a sea urchin or something that lives in a highly
variable like coastal intertidal,
right?
What do you do?
You just produce millions of gametes.
That's not an option for humans,
right?
Because we inherit this legacy of the great apes.
So we're trying to avoid us extinction given these enormous constraints on our
reproductive biology.
And again,
another,
another photo that I think really encapsulates so many of these,
these challenges that humans have and the embodiment of uncertainty in our life
histories,
uh,
is this incredible,
portrait fight by Dorothea Lange.
It's iconic photograph of Oklahoma Dust Bowl refugees.
And here's the mother in California with her infant son and,
and I heard her infant and it hurts her young school age son.
This is weird.
I,
I'm just,
we take it for granted because it's,
it's humans.
You know,
you expect it.
A young mother has,
has a bunch of young kids,
but it's really weird.
A chimpanzee mother birth intervals of about five and a half years in Gombe
national park in Tanzania and other places where I've worked.
Um,
and uh,
she will wean her infant that starts that in her hole right at about age five,
four or five.
And she will then never invest in that child again and economically,
she will never share food with that child again.
She will never nurse that child again.
Could you imagine doing that to this?
Good.
Sorry,
five year old,
we've got a new baby.
You got to make it on your own.
Right?
That's not an option for human.
Even those of you who haven't had kids probably know that,
right?
Sometimes you wonder with Stanford Students,
You have to explain that,
that that won't work.
But you know,
I assume you guys know,
um,
so allocation does,
uncertainty is embodied in our very reproductive biology.
Given its central importance.
It probably comes into our economic decision making as well.
Now I'm going to,
I don't have much time left.
I'm going to talk about too,
um,
specific applications very quickly.
Um,
so here is a schematic model and I just put in the types of economic decisions.
I tend to think about as a reminder,
we've got these four economic decisions are lotteries in the sense that they,
they,
uh,
they have variable payoffs,
right?
These are decisions that have variable payoffs and we call them lotteries.
And in the standard economic analysis,
you have these different lotteries and they get aggregated by a thing called
utility.
Okay?
The utility,
uh,
aggregates,
it averages over these things.
And you're trying to maximize that.
And when people start thinking about,
well,
how do we mix economics and evolutionary biology,
it's tempting to first simply substitute fitness for,
for utility.
But that's wrong for two reasons.
First,
no one.
But sociopath's thinks about maximizing their fitness.
You know,
you say,
Oh,
I must have more babies.
And they,
you know,
and the,
and I must compete with,
you know,
people don't think that way.
That's not,
that's not something that's about,
you know,
sort of fitting into the observations.
Again.
Uh,
but second,
and more importantly,
it would be a terrible control variable for your,
for your behavior because fitness is measured at a timescale that's basically
greater than a human lifespan,
right?
It's about your contribution to future generations.
You can't sit there and have a real time feed of your fitness,
right?
You need something more proximate,
uh,
to,
use fitness ends up being the arbiter of what things work and what things don't.
But you want to have something proximate that you,
that you can use as a control variable,
okay.
Uh,
to,
to respond,
to adopt a adaptively to a changing environment.
All right?
So,
uh,
utility,
in the standard economic model aggregates over average and averages over
different lotteries nor model that I've already shown you,
right?
The lotteries are still there.
We've got these aggregators that approximate level,
these are these,
these and these sort of,
um,
uh,
these proximate motivational systems,
satiety,
sexual satisfaction,
love of your children,
what,
you know,
whatever,
whatever they are.
But what matters is that they are,
are things that you can use to guide your decisions right over how,
how you decide to mix your,
your uh,
your market basket for example.
And then fitness is the thing that aggregates over the top of this.
This is a,
a model hierarchical model that Mike Price and I put together and we've done a
bunch of things with it.
It turns out there a system of equations that underlying us.
We can put some,
some,
some constraints on there and there's actually a whole talk where I talk about
the constraints cause it's,
it's,
it's sort of surprising and interesting where they come from.
Um,
and we have results.
Here are three very quickly distortion of decision weights,
kind of like prospect theory.
If,
if the,
you know,
the standard economic analysis when you have a risky decision to make is that
you're trying to maximize the expected value of your utility and thinking about
what expected value means.
It means that you have a linear combination of some weights.
They happen to be probabilities,
but their decision weights and,
and some outcomes,
right?
It's a linear combination.
It looks like people aren't putting together linear combinations of weights and,
and outcomes.
Okay.
They're using some sort of weird curvilinear thing that,
uh,
Kahneman and Tversky have suggested looks,
looks Kinda like that when we use,
when we use fitness as a,
as a criterion,
as a objective function,
right?
What we get is decision weights that curve like that.
Okay.
So that was cool.
Uh,
another thing is high risk aversion among the poorest people.
There's this idea,
it's kind of this folklore,
I think that that poor people have nothing to lose somehow,
you know,
in the sense that they're very resource poor and so they should be willing,
they're natural entrepreneurs,
right?
They should be willing to take risks because when they got to lose,
well,
what they have to lose when you think of us as,
as biological entities is they have everything to lose,
right?
They're poor and just,
uh,
and,
and so if their,
if their financial decisions,
if their economic decisions have an impact on their survivability,
then uh,
we should expect them to be actually risk averse.
And in this framework,
it turns out that they're extremely risk averse.
Okay.
And then finally,
uh,
we can recover without any sort of active choice.
These,
the what looked like preference reversals,
some of the classic paradoxes of choice that came about in the,
in the 1950s that's a little more technical,
but it's a cool result to,
um,
just want to remind you as I get to my last point here about the diversity of
habitats that humans live in,
right?
We come out onto the Savannah.
We can live in these,
in these mixed rain forest.
Agricultural lands is in Uganda.
Again,
we live in the Tundra,
right?
And the art inside the Arctic Circle.
Harrison,
some Venezuela and Yanos home of swamps and big snakes.
Right?
This is where anacondas live.
Um,
people are very,
they're very successful hunter gatherers who live there.
We live on the,
the coastal shore as Fisher Fisher folk.
We live on temperate prairie's,
right.
We have a wide variety of,
of habitats and presumably are,
are sort of choice.
Calculus should be a little different depending on where we're actually making
our decisions.
So as generalists with tremendous capacity to learn,
it seems reasonable to suppose that human,
the human capacity to make rational decisions has an ontogeny,
right?
Meaning it has a development,
you have to learn a little bit about it.
Okay.
And I've,
I've developed a simple model of learning about one's uncertain environment that
helps understand one of the most vexing results in,
in this irrationality literature,
which is inconsistent time preferences,
right?
The fact that we,
we,
we value,
uh,
like waiting a day differently,
whether it's today or whether it's next year,
right?
We care a lot about waiting from today til tomorrow,
but we don't care that much at all,
you know,
a year,
and a day from now or whatever it's,
it's a year from now.
This drives economists crazy.
Right?
It may seem common sense to people.
I think that that's an interesting insight.
Um,
but it does drive economist crazy.
It's one of the fundamental,
uh,
anomalies.
So I have a simple model of,
of,
uh,
that has basically four parts.
The first is that your time preferences?
Why do we care about the present more than the future?
Well,
a reasonable way to think about that is because there's,
there's the chance that you might die before you recover.
A reward that you delay or less dramatically that reward might go away,
right?
Your friend might forget or it might be a resource that that,
uh,
gets swooped on,
right?
So there's a,
there's a hazard of failure,
uh,
of,
of this resource and you can then have a time consistent prior,
which is like an exponential distribution,
right?
That you value all,
all delays,
uh,
of the same,
same amount,
by the same,
by the same amount.
That's your prior distribution,
right?
Consistent with the prior,
you can then go out and learn about the environment,
but a lot of these important economic decisions,
things about like how,
how what you plant this year yields,
you're your yield.
I,
you know,
nine months from now,
a year from now,
you don't have a lot of opportunities as a kid to learn about that.
You have a few,
so you're probably at best going to learn about it with uncertainty when you
integrate the uncertainty of it.
So the posterior,
it looks pretty good here,
right?
I figured,
again,
I'm on fairly safe ground Google based,
right?
Um,
your posterial looks pretty good,
but in fact when you integrate it to give us your personal,
your predictive distribution,
all of a sudden you've got all of that uncertainty that that causes this big,
um,
plateau here.
And it essentially turns into what's known as hyperbolic discounting,
right?
So it's an inconsistency in time preference because you've got this fat tail
that you have to integrate over.
So,
uh,
uncertainly in discount rate leads to inconsistent time preferences.
There is the exponential production,
right?
The discount rate with no uncertainty is exponential.
You add uncertainty and what you get is essentially the,
uh,
this hyperbolic function.
I was really excited when I read it because it's really simple model,
right?
It's just a,
it's just a simple little Bayesean model.
I was like,
wow,
I really nailed it this time.
It turns out.
Then I,
I then went back to the literature.
It turns out a bunch of people who said it,
this is always a bitter sweet moment.
On the one hand you're like,
damn,
I thought it was so original.
But on the other hand,
it means that I had the same good idea that Partha Dasgupta had.
And that's always a good thing,
right?
So you know,
you win some,
you lose some.
So I'm going to give you three takeaways.
Maximizing fitness distorts economic choices,
right?
We,
we've seen this repeatedly,
but it maximizes fitness,
right?
And that's the,
that's the direction that selection is going to push the population.
Uncertainty changes,
optimality predictions.
Qualitatively,
when you put uncertainty into the game,
you get different answers.
And that evolutionary theory has promised for providing a comprehensive theory
of choice.
It's very much a work in progress.
I'm excited about the potential here.
I'm going to excited about trying to recruit some more people to work on this.
And I had to thank you for your time and I'm happy to entertain.
Yeah.
Hello.
So,
um,
I am a,
it's the question about,
uh,
the role of like social signaling and economic decisions.
I'm thinking there's two,
there's that game economic,
economic economist like to point to is a rational where,
you know,
two people can split a pile of money.
It makes an offer.
The other accepts or rejects.
Yep.
Typically,
if it's asymmetric,
second one will reject and no one wins anything.
Yeah.
Um,
which to me it seems like that's because like a tribal environment,
you're trying to teach other people,
you know,
don't try it.
Costly punishment.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean,
so this is another area that has actually gotten a lot more attention I think
from evolutionary anthropologists and evolutionary biologists is,
is what's sometimes called our pro sociality,
right?
This intense social sociality that we have that's reflected in these food
sharing networks.
Right.
But that we have the psychology of we don't like unfairness.
And,
and,
uh,
and when you play the dictator game,
right,
you,
you punish people,
uh,
w w who don't give fair,
what you perceive to be fair offers and that presumably this,
this relates to this,
this need for ensuring cooperation and small scale societies and punishing
cheaters.
Yeah.
Thanks for that
question.
Related question.
So if we're really concerned about comfort and survival and things like that,
it's amazing that humans will migrate to some of the most uncomfortable places
and will willingly venture out with why would a rational creature and go to the
South Pole,
go to the moon,
go to Mars,
the interest,
they're not very pleasant.
Um,
do we as creatures is going to be rather curious that make us different from
other animals?
Yes.
You know,
there are a lot,
I think that anything that makes its living as a generalist is,
is,
is going to be curious.
I mean,
lots,
lots of primates are super curious,
right?
I mean,
if,
if you live around here and you have a,
like,
like French doors,
you've possibly seen raccoons at your door to sort of like looking in like,
hey,
what's going on in there?
Right.
So I don't know if curiosity,
we certainly,
I think take curiosity into another level.
All of those things.
Uh,
you know,
if you go to Mars and you come back,
that's a pretty high status thing to do,
right?
You,
you,
you have,
you have a social signaling going on right?
If you come back now,
right.
And,
and if you think about my,
my Bayesean model,
right,
how many opportunities do you have to learn about what the actual hazard is?
You know,
supposedly I have a,
like a really flat prior,
you know,
you've never seen anyone go to Mars,
so,
you know,
it could be anything.
Right.
Um,
so I think that that sort of explains some of the,
the,
the unusual sort of decisions that people seem to make moving into the Arctic
to,
uh,
to live.
Right.
It may seem uncomfortable to us,
but you know,
if you're in Yoga,
you do pretty well in general,
right.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
the,
there's a living to be made there and,
and people are incredibly adaptable.
Question,
thanks for the talk.
Do you see any other species that have environment involved in uncertain
environments that share a similar pattern in reproductive power or other
characteristics?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Um,
I don't really know.
There's,
there is a sort of the classic bet hedgers are there a bunch of birds?
Like again,
local environment,
red tail hawks,
right?
So a lot of,
a lot of the raptors,
we'll do this thing that really kind of perplexing at face value.
They'll lay clutches of two eggs,
but only one will ever fledge.
Right.
And,
and it seems incredibly wasteful.
Right.
And it's a classic bed hedging thing.
If that first one fails,
then the second one is there.
Right.
And,
and the cost,
you're paying a little bit of your mean,
you know,
you're paying out a little insurance policy,
right.
For catastrophic to insure against catastrophic failure.
So there are lots of birds that engage in this type of bed.
Um,
reproductive power,
uh,
as I've called it,
I've not seen it in any mammal.
It's possible it exists in other,
but you know,
the way the,
the,
the churn off model works.
It,
you have to,
for this model,
you have to be a mammal.
Like you could come up with,
with these sort of dimensionalist design features of different life histories,
but it only works for,
you know,
if you have the same kind of general reproductive biology.
Yeah.
So in,
in light of your research,
maybe academically you wouldn't make any recommendations like this been
personally,
do you have recommendations on how to motivate people psychologically in
collectively to address issues like climate change?
You know,
we're feeling in the present now will be feeling a lot more with other,
well,
I have,
I have pretty strong opinions about the way we value the future.
And I think that,
um,
you know,
it,
it seems,
you know,
like a,
it's a,
it's a bit of a moral argument.
But,
um,
when we say,
you know,
we want to take some steps to mitigate climate change.
Now whenever we do a cost benefit analysis,
what's going to happen is that you're going to take a discount rate,
right?
Uh,
of,
of the value of,
of an investment today,
you know,
a couple of hundred years in the future.
And that's,
that's the real rub.
It's both that the fact that,
uh,
you're,
you're valuing the president more than the future,
but you're also,
all these things play out at very long time scales.
So you throw in a 4% discount rate and you know,
it's very difficult to come up with a cost benefit analysis that favors
mitigation.
Now with a 4% discount rate that pays out,
you know,
its benefits in 200 years.
So I think,
and I'm not alone in this,
there,
there are a bunch of environmental economists who,
who are engaged in a very vigorous debate on this,
that we should use much lower discount rates,
uh,
for thinking about cost benefit analysis with these long payoffs.
Uh,
Martin Weitzman at Harvard is suggested using the absolute lowest discount rate
that you can,
that you can imagine,
uh,
that that makes it tenable,
um,
because of this problem,
right?
Um,
and because the,
the tail risk of these outcomes are so huge,
right?
Um,
so that's something I take away from this.
Like,
like,
uh,
don't overvalue the present,
but it's easy for me to do that.
I live in Palo Alto,
right?
We all live in pretty predictable environments,
We're quite privileged people and it's easy to say,
well you know,
we shouldn't really value the future.
And this is some of the work that my colleagues who I showed you briefly I've
done showing that,
you know,
if you're a poor,
so like they're the classic marshmallow experiments that were done here at
Stanford,
right?
And you know,
give a kid a marshmallow and walkaway,
say,
don't eat that.
Right?
Cause if you do,
that's all you're getting.
But if it's still there when I come back and get to right,
and you walk away and it turns out that you know,
these kids who struggle to,
they're looking at this marshmallow,
then I think,
oh God,
I want eat the marshmallow.
So Dad,
right?
It turns out that it correlates very well.
The,
your ability to put off that reward and get the larger reward after a little
delay predicts a lot of things about your success in,
in,
in life.
Um,
it's really hard.
Anthropologists have found it really hard to go into places and,
and replicate these types of economic games that we play all the time,
including,
you know,
that dictator games.
And these,
these,
these things that we talked about before,
um,
in part because people are like,
how do I know you're going to be back with your two marshmallows that you talked
about?
I had to take that one right now.
Thank you very much.
Right?
And so that's just a cautionary tale that it's easy for me to say we should
value the future more because,
you know,
I,
I have a pretty low discount rate because,
you know,
I live in Palo Alto.
Um,
as a society I think we should be modeling,
uh,
the,
the future,
um,
uh,
valuing the future more than we do.
That's a really long answer to pretty straight forward question.
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Vietnam and get 7 million people.
It's really,
I mean,
that's a vexing problem,
right?
That,
that we sort of develop these,
these,
uh,
these ingroup and outgroup identities and that they probably are very functional
when you live in a band like society because you know,
you're in group is really your everything,
right?
It's maybe not so functional when,
uh,
when you're,
you're,
you make,
you know,
the rest of the world,
your outgroup right.
And,
and you know,
the same sort of rules of morality don't apply to them and that sort of thing.
Um,
that's a real problem.
And,
and I,
and solving that,
you know,
there's,
there's a prize for someone,
right?
Uh,
is,
is if we can figure out how to really begin to address that.
Um,
equally importantly in the world we live in,
when you're a peasant farmer and you plant yams and,
and you know,
some maize and whatever,
you know,
you sort of,
you place your bet and then you tend to it and,
and you hopefully get a big payoff,
right?
There's a direct
causal interpretation of what you do and what you get in the world we live in,
we have all this complexity and we don't necessarily pay the costs for bad
decisions right away.
And I think that makes it very hard to learn about good decision making.
Right?
And so,
uh,
there are a number of people who have developed sort of the curricula for
teaching kids how to,
how to make risky decisions.
I think that,
um,
giving kids some responsibility and getting them some skin in the game is a
really important thing.
So that's a little off of,
of your question,
but I think that that's another real challenge to thinking about how our brains
were designed to make decisions and the types of environments in which we have
to do it now.
Many of us.
Yeah.
If we predict greatly increased variability in the near future,
what would you predict,
uh,
with those functions,
eg longing,
longevity or things like that?
Well,
first of all,
we have to get through this possible bottleneck,
right?
Um,
and,
and I say that flippantly because I otherwise I just descend into depression.
Right?
Uh,
I'm sure it's conceivable that,
you know,
there could be more selection on even more spread out,
uh,
reproduction.
I mean,
the thing is that,
okay,
a really interesting observation that we make in development economics and
demography is that as soon as you can insure the more or less certain survival
of your kids to reproductive age,
people voluntarily reduce their fertility,
right?
They like,
and,
and so we had this model,
um,
uh,
called the demographic transition model and predicted the sort of timescale over
which has happened and it seemed to explain the historical data very well.
And then,
you know,
late in the 20th century,
these places like a lot of places in the,
in the Middle East and North Africa and in Asia,
you know,
in the tiger economies,
like fertility felt like that as soon as kids,
uh,
could be counted on to,
to survive.
Um,
and so
yeah,
if we can,
if,
if our sort of technological and social technologies can keep up with ensuring
the child's survivorship,
right,
and,
and keeping,
uh,
the,
it,
keeping it favoring,
you know,
economic investment,
then that sort of relaxes the selection pressure to spread everything out.
For sure.
Uh,
and I think that that should be a goal that we have right.
If,
if we want to,
if we want to avoid sort of negative population consequences,
make sure that kids,
that kids survived to adulthood,
right?
Because that changes everything about people's investments.
And that's really what,
what,
what this,
you know,
given that you can't affect that,
right.
As a,
as a homicide and it,
you know,
a million years ago,
right?
You don't have the technology to really mitigate that.
Right?
So what you do is you spread everything out,
but if we have the chance to actually solve it right,
then that's the better solution probably.
And that also,
uh,
sort of reduces the selective pressure,
I think.
Yeah.
Thanks.
[inaudible].